democracy is easy it's like stealing ice
cream from a baby I genuinely love the
process of manipulating people online
for money we just want to predict your
future behaviors these videos are all
deep fakes synthesize content created
using artificial intelligence deep fakes
will make for even more complicated
arguments about what is fake news and
what is real and if seeing is no longer
believing the very real question is
could deep fakes weaken democracy
democracy just doesn't work if people
don't believe in it so the deep fake
artworks used artificial intelligence
and machine learning technologies to
kind of Huck and the bodies if you like
famous celebrity influences bill posters
is the artist behind these deep fake
videos known as the spectre project
[Music]
spectra is almost too powerful to
comprehend through the many questions he
wants to explore the specs projectors
what does it feel like well personal
data is used in unexpected ways mites
powerful tech companies and harbors a
resort
cannot change our understandings of
today to test Facebook's response bill
posted the deep fake videos on
instagrams a social media platform owned
by Facebook the company downgraded the
videos visibility Spectre showed me how
to manipulate you into sharing intimate
data about yourself and all those you
loved for free but that didn't stop this
fake clip of Facebook boss Mark
Zuckerberg going viral that showed the
potential for spreading disinformation
online through deep fakes a danger
that's likely to increase as long as
tech companies and politicians remain
unsure how to deal with it
the power of deep fakes is an area of
great concern and whilst these
technologies existing what is
essentially a regulation black hole
image manipulation is already exploited
by autocratic regimes it's a dark heart
that goes back to Joseph Stalin who made
his enemies disappear today is capable
of making deep fake videos like this
where comedian Bill Hader morphs into
Tom Cruise as the technology advances
the danger is that deep fakes will be
used to mislead voters in democratic
countries
[Applause]
[Music]
if you take away those tools that enable
us to be able to sort out what's real
from what's not you make very poor
decisions Aviva vodka is the founder of
thoughtful technology project he worries
about another problem the deep fakes
could be used as an excuse to help
politicians escape scrutiny
you have the corrupt politician being
able to say oh yeah that video of me
that was fake that brings them to a
world where people won't know what they
can trust
he believes the ultimate threat from
deep fakes could be that more and more
people opt out of democratic politics a
phenomenon he calls reality apathy
reality apathy is when it's so hard to
make sense of what's happening people
just sort of give up democracy just
doesn't work if people don't believe in
it
so what can be done to fight back a
group of scientists at Cambridge
University are having a go they have
developed a computer game to teach
people how to spot disinformation so in
the game people essentially step into
the shoes of a fake news producer and
you're build your way up to a fake news
empire by spreading fake content online
dr. sandy van der Linden
the game's designer believes it will
help people to distinguish fact from
fiction your goal is to get as many
followers as possible while maintaining
your online credibility so he can't be
too ridiculous and the first badge in
the game is about impersonating other
people online and of course one example
that we've talked about is deep fake so
you create so in the game we test people
before and after and at the beginning we
found that people are duped by a lot of
these techniques but once they played
the game they've become resistant and
are able to identify them later on dr.
van der Linden team have drawn
inspiration from preventative medicine
in their hunt to cure fake news so just
as you inject someone with severely
weakened dose of a virus to trigger
antibodies in the immune system that you
can do the same with information people
can essentially create mental antibodies
and become immune against fake news and
essentially everyone is their own
[ __ ] detector today I'm president
not because I'm the greatest they're
probably a deep fake technology means
that faking videos is becoming as easy
as faking words and photos until people
learn to look at video with a more
critical eye there's a danger that deep
fakes could be used to undermine
democracy
you
[Applause]